inflation in the united states stands at
a 40-year high and it doesn't look like
it's slowing down anytime soon this has
led to the federal reserve increasing
interest rates and conducting
quantitative tightening now larry
summers the former treasury secretary in
a speech yesterday in london went ahead
and said that may not be enough he
actually thinks that we have to have a
five percent unemployment rate in order
to combat inflation now if we go look at
his exact statement what we can see is
that larry summers said we need five
years of unemployment above five percent
to contain inflation in other words we
need two years of seven point five
percent unemployment or five years of
six percent unemployment or one year of
ten percent unemployment there are
numbers that are remarkably discouraging
relative to the fed reserve view
now many people may ask what the hell
does it have to do inflation and
unemployment but let me walk you through
how this chain of events usually occurs
inflation is very high right now and so
the federal reserve wants to combat it
they're going to raise interest rates
and they're going to conduct that
quantitative tightening as they do that
they are trying to destroy demand if
there's less demand for goods and
services in the economy that means
businesses revenue will go down if their
revenue goes down all of a sudden they
become much much more concerned about
surviving any sort of market downturn if
you're worried about surviving you want
to make sure that you have a strong
balance sheet and if you need to have a
strong balance sheet that means you have
to get your expenses under control
normally when people look to their
balance sheet and look to cut expenses
one of the areas that they will cut
first is layoffs so one of the things
that you're likely to see in the coming
months is in anticipation of a market
downturn many businesses will start to
lay off employees and as they begin to
do that many of those companies will
have a direct impact on the unemployment
rate going up currently we sit around
3.5 percent it's a historic low similar
to where we were right before the
pandemic started but as businesses start
to prepare for potential recession or
some sort of bad environment that rising
interest rate that quantitative
tightening it is ultimately going to
lead to business owners trying to
anticipate the future they are going to
start to quell their expenses they are
going to start to lay people off and i
would expect the unemployment rate to go
up now will it get five percent or more
for five years will it be ten percent
for a single year i don't know i don't
have a crystal ball but what i do know
is that larry summers understands how
the economy works and he realizes that
the federal reserve is gonna have to get
tougher on the inflation story or else
we risk inflation getting out of control
so at the end of the day the federal
reserve will continue to raise interest
rates and conduct quantitative
tightening until something breaks in the
meantime businesses see what's going on
they'll start laying people off and the
unemployment rate will definitely rise